sorry hon but I'm gonna tell you the
odds
[Music]
so normally today would have been my
Westworld review but i am on the night
that i am recording this instead of the
west-world review to put out on monday
i'm gonna be up late on on some other
projects and i'm not gonna get to
Westworld until tomorrow so that'll be
Tuesday so instead I'm gonna take what I
had originally planned you'll be Tuesday
splot splot good ha this is off to a
good start
just a slot and put it here and which is
that I want to talk about what solo
means for the future of the Star Wars
franchise now originally when I was
conceiving this as a concept I thought
it was mainly just gonna be talking
about what it meant as far as what it
indicates for narrative things in what
it indicates about how Lucasfilm is
processing these and what my thoughts on
whether or not it gave me hope for the
other projects from a strictly
storytelling perspective I am still
gonna talk about that but I'm also gonna
have to bring in the box office because
it turned out to not be what it was
supposed to be projections for this
thing had it as high as 115 million for
its opening weekend as of today this is
Sunday when they can pretty safely wrap
up the three day estimate it's coming in
at 83 million that's low that's
especially low compared to its what was
expected of it now yes I understand this
is in fact the three-day weekend with
Memorial Day but even on a three-day
weekend even when they pat out the stats
with that Friday and Saturday is still
the big days and it didn't do great
on the big days so yes if you choose to
count from Memorial Day that will bring
it up a little bit but looking at it as
a standard weekend which ultimately is
how it's generally gonna be judged this
is not good and it flat out flopped in
China and open soft and a lot of other
overseas markets so oh boy yeah uh-huh
I remember saying after the last jet
that there might have been some
scrambling after that second weekend had
a really big drop it but this is this
isn't just a big drop this is a bad open
and that is a whole new can of worms for
Lucasfilm and Kathleen Kennedy to be
dealing with now I will say that it is
possible that for whatever reason this
is just a weird weekend because also
Deadpool like plummeted over 70% like
way more than what I would have 5 what
had done for a perfectly fine movie that
opened well so maybe this is just
something we're going on with this
weekend but regardless of any external
reason on paper this is bad this is
still really bad so if you want a
comparison so that I'm not just throwing
a number out with no context the last
I'm not you know what I almost was gonna
compare it to the last Jedi opening
let's not even go there because this
main saga entries always do better I say
always this is only our second spin-off
the context is all weird on this okay
let's compare to rogue one instead rogue
one which is the other side cool that
opened at 155 million so this is way way
way way behind that but if you want
another point of comparison this is the
first Star Wars movie to open in summer
as opposed to in December
since Revenge of the Sith back in 2005
and that opened at 105 million Soho a
movie that was a that was a the closing
episode and a trilogy that a lot of
people weren't liking 13 years ago
opened better than solo did yeah
I really I don't know I don't know how
secure Kathleen Kennedy's got to be
feeling at this point because she is
gonna bear a fair amount of the blame
for this because we don't know and we
ought and when I say me we I mean
audience members we will we don't know
we will probably never know exactly what
it was Lord Miller were getting up to
and whether or not was any good honestly
it could've been way worse than the
movie and honestly if you didn't see my
review solo is not bad solos find it so
it's just kind of unremarkable that
might be part of the problem
but I'll come back to that so she she
got involved because she took Lord
Miller out she got Ron Howard in and
this was on her authority this was on
her say-so and I have to imagine that
people above her the people actually at
Disney with control over things even
higher than than her head of the higher
than her power reaches have to be
looking at this looking at the REE the
very divided reaction to the last Jedi
looking at the reception to rogue one
which was decent but it seems to be
getting beaten up in retrospect so does
force awakens' for that matter and they
have to be going is are we steering this
ship wrong now for my money episode 9 is
you gotta be largely unaffected by this
it's episode 9 still happens cuz they
have to make episode 9 what may be and
more of a question I actually I would
put the big question mark right now over
Ryan Johnson's proposed trilogy because
and this is me assuming a little bit but
my assumption has been that he got that
gig getting to do trilogy of films not
as part of the main series basically on
the strength of how good his working
relationship with Kathleen Kennedy
wasn't how much she liked his pitch but
you really have to think that her
judgment has got to be called into
question at this point with what has
gone on in the both the production and
now the diminished box offices alleles
last few films and when I said that solo
was just fine that honestly could be
part of the problem because I think you
look it's really hard for us to truly
properly gauge exactly what percentage
ish of fans of Star Wars really didn't
like the last Jedi it's hard to judge
because the people who didn't like it
really didn't like in our extremely
vocal about it and it makes them seem
louder than their numbers might in fact
be it's difficult to judge it I
believe it to be a significant portion
of the audience though and I I don't
think it goes so far as people coming
out of last I going I'm never watching
anything no Star Wars again but I do
think that was probably a fair number of
people who either didn't like the last
Jedi or have been nervous about the
franchise going forward who came out and
went you know what if it does if solo
doesn't look spectacular
I might just skip it and when the
reviews came out and said yeah it's fine
it's good it's fun and which was my
reaction more or less I have to imagine
there's a fair amount of the audience
that went they all wait for streaming
because this is the first Star Wars film
that I can remember where or at least
since the prequels where there isn't at
least somebody I know going oh this was
this was great it was so much fun you
know because there I regardless of my
own feelings about them I know people
who love the force awakens I know people
who love the last Jedi
I know people who love rogue one I don't
know anybody who loves this and actually
most of my friends who are like opening
day Star Wars goes I'm one of only two
people I know that's actually seen this
movie by now that's not to say my other
friends won't get to it but I think Star
Wars as a whole is is not destination
viewing anymore they might be milking
this to death and the combination of
having put out a film that's just fine
combined with the fact that they won
Star Wars movie or frankly might be too
much and I still think it was a bad idea
to release this in summer I've always
thought that I don't know why they gave
up the December release date because
they literally owned it they won't of
that release date I don't know so that's
that's sort of how the box office is
shaking out that yeah
Kathleen Kennedy has got to be really
worried right now and she's probably got
a lot of uncomfortable meetings and
awkward questions to be answered about
how she's going to write the ship like I
said episode 9 still happens Ryan
Johnson's trilogy possibly iffy the boat
that movie that probably still happens
because there's enough fans or at least
that have been historically who go we
love a fact that the studio will
probably think that's a good idea
regardless obi-wan movie assuming that
they are still moving forward and that
we haven't heard anything in a while but
that probably still moves forward but
beyond that III imagine things have to
be have to be very much up in the air at
the moment so that's the financial end
of it in terms of the the narrative
issues or at least what the narrative
and the my feelings about the film you
know what it says to me
here's why it makes me nervous now
I know a lot of people really like to
blame Kathleen Kennedy for things that
have gone on and the last couple of Star
Wars movies I would say
disproportionately so honestly
especially when it comes to the last
Jedi if you're gonna be mad at somebody
be mad at Rian Johnson he made the movie
he wrote the movie Kevin Kennedy is not
a creative she's she's just she's she's
an executive she exerts her influence
but she she didn't come up with any of
those ideas those were Rian Johnson's
ideas that said she's not blameless the
way I put it was I I don't like a lot of
what Rian Johnson did in that movie and
I don't want to rehash my issues with
the last Jedi I'll simply reiterate
they're not what a lot of people have I
don't have you know the problems with
Rey getting her powers or you know a lot
of the or what was done with Luke those
aren't problems that I actually have
with that film but I still don't like it
but the the thing is is even though I
said despite my issues I don't
necessarily blame Rian Johnson for
making them because that was the movie
he wanted to make I do kind of blame
Kathleen Kennedy as the overseer for
allowing him to do it
like I get why he why he might have
thought these were good ideas I just
don't understand how there weren't
people above him looking at at least
some of these ideas and going actually
we'd rather you didn't do that that's
potentially brain
and damaging so that was that was the
extent to which I was prepared to blame
Kathleen Kennedy I never actively blamed
her for that movie and rogue one I kind
of shrugged off because at the time it
was a one-off it was a fluke essentially
but now between a rogue one and solo
we've got two movies with incredibly
publicly troubled shooting and massive
reshoots and a lot of influence being
exerted by her and and the other
Lucasfilm
top brass at the tail end of production
and well first of all that that racks up
the costs on these things because you
have to shoot a whole bunch more stuff
so it makes it all it inherently makes
these things already more expensive than
they should have been in the first place
but beyond that especially in the case
of solo it really does bring into
question her I don't want to say her
ability to run a studio because that's
that's a that's a skill set I honestly
don't know a ton about but what it does
bring into question is her ability to
judge artistic quality which honestly is
something that you can call most studio
executives judgment into question on
that actually pretty much all of them
that's actually really standard but the
difference is is most studio executives
aren't overseeing a single franchise and
when a studio executive is basically in
charge of only one thing you'd like to
think they have a decent grasp on a
sense of what that thing being done well
would look like so like I mean you know
Kevin Feige is the golden boy of all
this the man somehow manages to rock
Marvel Studios understand these
characters know what's gonna work no
it's gonna sell and keep a very smooth
operation going
he really does seem to be the complete
exception to this though so what I mean
where what I mean by solo brings
Kathleen Kennedy's ability to judge
artistic quality into question is the
the primary reason given for the removal
of Lord and Miller and and and I will
grant them are very well might be other
things but this was the main reason
given so it's what I'm gonna deal with
was that they were Lee they were not
sticking to the script they were going
off script way way way too much and it
was causing a tone issue and it made the
whole thing goofy it made it not what
they wanted but they weren't sticking to
the script and Kathleen Kennedy really
went to bat for the script by Lawrence
and Jonathan Kasdan and that means that
that script kinda needed to be
phenomenal because if her basis for
cutting loose the previous directors was
their inability to stick to that script
but that script is just fine it's what
you'd expect then that shows that she is
coming at these from a headspace and an
understanding of the material that might
not be the best one because when I came
out of solo and I thought about that
story I thought about the scripting
because I mentioned this in a previous
video before when you get Ron Howard to
direct Ron Howard he's very much a
journeyman director and that can be used
as a derogatory term sometimes but he's
a very good journeyman director but what
I mean by that is he doesn't reshape a
script he takes a script and he'll shoot
it the way that he thinks is best to be
shot but Ron Howard doesn't have a
particularly distinct flavor he's not an
auteur he's a guy who you give him the
script to shoot the script if you give
him a really good script he'll probably
deliver a really good movie but he can't
really elevate a script so when I look
at story issues of this I am I feel
comfortable chalking them up to the
script as opposed to saying it was
Howard's fall for mishandling it
and this script is fine but I look at
the things like
you try and suss out what possibly could
have been in here that would have gotten
an executive so excited and I can see
that stuff things like spoilers for solo
for what I'm about to talk so if you
care sorry I gotta talk about this but
stuff like Darth Maul being dropped and
clearly setting up if not his own movie
at least for him to be a running threat
in other side films that kind of
deliberate franchise synergy drop
executives love that because they see
that as franchise building the all the
connections that are made that you know
like an in excess of what is necessary
to the story things you know it's not
just a matter of Han getting the
Millennium Falcon we have to see me
Chewie for the first time we have to see
the the Kessel run we have to for some
reason we have to explain why the the
Falcons navicomputer is so good I don't
even know why but for some reason that
gets explained really bizarrely
we need to highlight how many capes
Lando has like that all these things
this sort of really interlocking thing
executives love that it's why the
exactly that's why it was set at these
Studios screening a Batman V Superman
the executives gave it a standing
ovation of course they did it's set up
at least four other films to follow
itself of course they loved it those
things those connections tying something
to something that is already known to be
loved while at the same time blatantly
and in this case number I don't think
especially well setting up what will
come next and what they can further
build from is exactly what executives
look for but of course all that stuff
kind of exists separate from whether or
not the script and the story and the
characters is actually any good and
again I don't want to over bag on this
script because it's not a bad script but
it's also not a phenomenal script it's
not a script worth appending a
production over
and that is what is causing me to bring
Kathleen Kennedy's artistic judgement
into question and that was something I
was planning on touching on even before
I looked at the box office but now that
on top of the box office if the folks at
Disney are basically asking the same
questions I am do you actually know what
you're looking for and do you actually
know how to deliver films that will make
us money and the answer to both those
questions is we're not so sure anymore I
wouldn't be shocked if there is a if
there is a shuffling that goes on at
Lucasfilm maybe maybe because episode 9
like I said that's gonna happen
regardless maybe that will be the letter
stay on and have that be her Hail Mary
play I see how well she handles whatever
part she takes in the development of
that but if episode 9 under performs as
well and also to be fair if episode 9
under performs that will probably have
more to do with people being upset from
the last Jedi which at this point is not
something she can control you know she
could oversee the creation of a
brilliant episode 9 but if it if it
tanks because fans are still annoyed
then it didn't matter how good she did
so but if episode 9 underperforms
notably I will be shocked if she's still
there so I don't I didn't mean to make
this overly about one specific person I
don't like to do that but she is the
overseer I mean she's she's as relevant
to this as Kevin Feige is to Marvel
movies so I feel like it as much as I
don't like making it about one person
because if nothing else that invites
people in my comment section making a
lot of personal attacks and that's the
kind of stuff I have to comb through and
get rid of but you know that's just the
state we're in the franchise as a whole
I really hope
that they get off this one Star Wars
movie a year kick I think I think it was
a bad idea like overall especially when
when we look at the stuff that they're
starting to develop and are working on
because look rogue one was an intriguing
premise because it was honestly a
completely new story it was something we
knew nothing about Solo is a much more
traditional prequel it fills in the gaps
pretty much as you would expect them to
be filled and that is harder to get
excited about and the frequency that
these things are coming out and also
coming out with them once a year you're
gonna start going with less and less
great ideas to be honest because it's
not like Marvel who has 50 years of
comic-book history and stories and
characters to draw from you guys got to
make this stuff up I mean you've got
characters you can spin off and build
from but you don't have the same pool of
stuff and guys don't cite me the
expanded universe because most of that
stuff even the stuff that was good it
was done in a way that was meant to work
as a book or as a comic or as a video
game and a lot of that stuff doesn't
translate elements do bits do that's why
thron showed up in rebels but especially
since they they have declared the
expanding universe non-canon and that's
not to say they won't borrow from it
they can they have they will they should
but they don't have the same base level
of solid foundation to be pulling
elements from I think one years was a
bad idea I think that we need to get
episode 9 focus on that don't give us a
Star Wars movie in 2020 and go to one
every two years because if your main
series is done
if the saga ends with episode 9 just
give a Star Wars movie every two years
because I know you've got you've got
Johnson on a trilogy so that you can
have him doing one every two years and
then plugging in a
star wars story and the alternating is
is too much guys you have to you have to
you have to back off go back to every
two years build the anticipation again
build the brand loyalty again help make
Star Wars not seem like every other
franchise again because that's what it's
starting to feel like now and that's
where it's just gonna wither if you keep
at it the way you're going so those are
my thoughts on the current state and
future of the Star Wars franchise what
are your thoughts on it whatever they
are as long as they don't involve
personal attacks seriously guys you can
hate Kathleen Kennedy I don't care just
don't do the personal attacks thing okay
but aside from that whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it there's
also the stuff to do you know the stop
the light gets subscribe and follow on
Twitter and then support on patreon buy
my t-shirt blah blah blah blah blah
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]